scp-682 vs scp-3042  could the ultimate case of puppy love be  the force to counteract scp-682's  reptilian hatred let's take a look and  see  scp-3042 is a small but superpowered dog  that bonds with one individual at a time  and basically gradually loves them to  death with constant and unyielding  affection its latest favorite person was  eaten by scp-682  causing scp-3042 to imprint on the  monster as a replacement however this  was disastrous as scp-682 immediately  attacked the tiny dog causing it to run  away in fear  scp-3042 charged through a nearby wall  thankfully making a hole too small for  scp-682 to escape through and imprinted  on a nearby guard another test  failed